what do you get when you cross a
competitive dancer a megaphone and a
businessperson Abby Lee Miller of course
third place second place it's just not
good enough in the Abby Lee dance
company
you either score the gold or you go home
we've seen Abby pick fights make people
cry and file lawsuits before breakfast
so don't mess with Abby unless you want
to be the best don't let her fool you
though
beneath that hard exterior is an le GUI
Center and we've got the footage to
prove it you don't take time to stop and
smell the roses Dance Moms is a reality
TV show that's jam-packed with drama but
that doesn't mean that the cast hasn't
shared hilarious moments along the way
we've got never-before-seen candy-apple
feuds mama drama and much much more
coming your way
Brynn teaches Kendall choreography we're
so used to burning Kendall bumping heads
that it's hard to believe that the girls
are actually quite chummy in real life
in this bonus scene from season 6
episode 10 we see Brynn teaching Kendall
choreography still immediately
complaints to Abby saying
why were you having Brynn teach the solo
in reality the operon is just teaching
Kendall a section of the duet but Jill
isn't about to let that slide while Jill
is bickering with Abby the girls work
together in perfect harmony and it's
clear that Kendall doesn't want her mom
interfering my mom just kind of needs to
shush and just let it all happen Abby
and Kendall cry together we're so used
to seeing Abby make her students cry
that were shocked to see Kendall make
her dance teacher tear up for once we
see a whole new side to Abby in this
bonus scene from season six and it's
sort of changes the way we look at her
after threatening to leave the ALDC Abby
tells Kendall to go home and make a list
of pros and cons before making a final
decision
when Abby and Kendall sit down to review
the list Abby starts crying when she
reads the part where Kendall feels like
she doesn't get to have fun anymore now
does that sound like something a
terribly mean person would do yeah we
didn't think so the kids did great
we adored Kristy Lucchesi ACK which is
why we love this deleted Dance Moms
scene it would have aired in season two
episode three but apparently the episode
had too much drama in it all
ready so they chose to cut it out in
this scene Abby says that the girls did
a good job despite Brooke bailing out on
the dance last second Christy goes on to
say that the kids did great which
creates tension in the room Abby refuses
to admit that the girls did a great job
and when the Dance Moms just won't quit
Abby loses her cool she tells them which
stops them dead in their tracks
Maddie forgets her dance who could
forget the time that Maddie Ziegler
forgot her dance the young star in the
making was totally embarrassed and
thought that Abby hated her but in this
deleted scene we see Abby hugging and
comforting Maddie behind the stage this
moment occurred in season 2 episode 13
but was later deleted from the episode
we also see a judge enter the back room
and ask Maddie if she wants another shot
but Abby is quick to dismiss him saying
the girl with the curly hair in this
bonus scene from season 5 episode 13 we
find out that Kira backstabbed the ALDC
and wrote an email to Cathy from the
candy apples Dance Center Cathy's
sidekick the obnoxious girl with the
curly hair enters the back room with a
printed out version of Tara's email The
Dance Moms find out that Kira thinks the
ALDC is garbage
rather than everyone on her team her
email causes a huge fight backstage and
Jill is picked to jump in and set the
record straight
Kira you better be careful with what you
say Rockette we're so used to seeing
Paige and Chloe fade into the background
that we were stunned to see how lively
they were in this deleted scene from
season 2 episode 14 a Rockette named
Michelle comes to visit the girls during
rehearsals and Chloe and Paige are super
talkative and hilarious when Michelle
asks the girls if any of them want to
become Rockettes Chloe and Paige's hands
go shooting up before Maddie can even
process the question now that's a first
Kendall's birthday bonus scene there's
no denying it every dancer at ALDC
worked super hard every single day but
that doesn't mean that there's no time
for fun in this bonus scene from season
6 episode 9 we see the girls celebrate
Kendall's 13th birthday everyone's in a
good mood and Kendall even jokes around
with Maddie saying this happy scene
didn't make the cut but at least we get
to see the girls celebrating in this
behind-the-scenes clip
just don't let Abby see you eating cake
Nia takes a sick day in this deleted
scene from season 6 episode 25 we see
Abby soft side pop up once again he has
got an ear infection and asked stab her
and Kendall's duet pushed back to a
later date my ears are really clogged
and I'm just instead of telling her to
suck it up Abby gives Nia the week off
and pairs Kendall up with Kalani instead
but instead of giving me as dance away
Abby gives the girls a different dance
the name of your routine is to be
determined and they go on to win first
place this deleted scene is proof that
Abby isn't as bad as she seems
the moms do the splits it's no secret
that many of the dance moms used to be
involved in competitive dancing when
they were younger I was one of Abby's to
do
ago so we weren't exactly shocked to see
some of the moms busting a move or two
in this bonus scene from season four
episode 16 the new moms show off their
skills by doing the splits and pointing
their toes to the sky
we love this bonus scene because it
shows the moms having some fun for a
change I can do my split Mary and their
girls seem totally impressed to Ashley's
at it again if there's one dance mom who
loves picking fights it's Ashley knowing
this we're not surprised that there are
plenty of Ashley inspired fights that
didn't make the final cut in this bonus
scene from season six episode two ashley
picks a fight with the moms and is later
quick to play the victim card ashley
starts bragging about her daughter Brynn
saying that she's one of the best Brynn
was the only one who pulled it off but
the other moms are quick to shut her
down Ashley even goes as far as to say
so which one of these deleted scenes was
your favorite let us know in the
comments section below for more videos
about your favorite movies and TV shows
subscribe to the things and don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up
thanks for watching we'll see you soon
[Music]